the final trailer for rogue one a Star
Wars story has arrived and it finally
pulls back the curtain on exactly what
fans can expect from the franchise's
first spin-off story just for you we
watched it 50 times and kept our eyes
peeled for things you might have missed
in the new rogue one trailer
father/daughter story with all the jump
cuts and mood lighting you might have
actually missed the central thrust of
the trailer which is that the whole
thing really boils down to a
father-daughter story which is sort of
familiar territory for this whole Star
Wars thing I'm Stan Kings tend when
Jin's father Galen is seized by
stormtroopers she's left behind to fend
for herself but when the rebels free her
years later it turns out dad is in fact
working for the Empire to create the
Death Star can they stop the Death Star
and save Daddy at the same time we need
to find him we'll find out that's one
big statue unlike the main star wars
saga films rub wand is not expected to
feature any Jedi in a meaningful way
Darth Vader excluded instead this has
been pitched as a story of regular folks
taking on the big bad Empire but this
gorgeous shot of a Ewing ship flying
over the remnants of a massive fallen
Jedi statue shows their influence is
still a part of this larger world hmm
Darth Vader looms large speaking of
Darth Vader the new footage here finally
shows him in action suggesting he may
play a bigger role than previously
expected could Vader's confrontation
with Imperial bad guy director cranek
happen after the rebel team inflict some
damage on the Death Star project
shipshape we weren't sure until now what
rogue one actually meant director Gareth
Edwards had previously told Empire
magazine that the film's title was more
of a metaphor for the project itself as
the first spin-off film not following
known characters like Luke Leia and the
rest of the gang but on screen we
learned that it's also the impromptu
call sign they come up with for their
ship during the mission rogue wrote one
it feels more hopeful it's no secret the
film went back in for extensive reshoots
a few months before its December 2016
release date with rumors swirling that
Disney wanted the film to look and feel
more
eat and hopeful and this attitude shows
in the trailer which has a vibe much
closer to that of the original Star Wars
a new hope
sure it's an us against the world story
but the rebels do still believe they can
win rebellions have built home hope the
team goes undercover as Imperial
officers one fleeting shot shows gem and
other members of a rebel strike team
disguises imperial officers could this
be the moment where they first break
into the imperial stronghold to find
Galen also for fans of the original
trilogy the undercover move is a classic
tactic to access empire facilities nice
callback Oh
seesaw Forest Whitaker is playing a
mysterious man who should be very
familiar to fans of Star Wars the Clone
Wars who are you I'm soccer era it's
true Whitaker has been confirmed as salt
Guerrera a rebel hero bringing in the
character mark Star Wars first major
crossover from the TV show to film and
not the other way around
Guerrera was introduced in the Clone
Wars animated series as a young man now
years later saw his all grown-up and
live-action in rogue one awesome
alienation it wouldn't be a Star Wars
movie if we didn't get to meet a few new
alien species but this design certainly
looks like it was pulled from Mad Max
fury road director George Miller's
sketchbook
despite the immortan joe vibe though
this alien named ed rio two tubes is
actually an ally of sagar era we're glad
he's on our side
space fights the force awakens was
pretty great but it was lacking in one
key area space battles that looks a
change in rogue one the footage here
shows a fleet of X wings attacking a
large Imperial ship in space
finally well guan is putting the star
wars back in star wars birth of the
rebellion the rebel planning scenes like
the one here echo the feel of the
original trilogy before the rebellion
took the Empire head-on in a new hope
these desperate rebel leaders were
figuring out how to join forces on their
first major mission in other words were
finally bearing witness to the birth of
the rebellion as we first knew it
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw
and leave us a comment to let us know
what you think of the rogue one trailer